>> Laura: A MAJOR VICTORY FOR
THE DEFENDERS OF OUR NATION'S
HISTORY AND A BIG REBUKE FOR
THOSE TRYING TO ERASE AMERICA'S
PAST.
IN THE WAKE OF THOSE DEADLY
PROTESTS AND CHARLOTTESVILLE,
VIRGINIA, THE CITY COUNCIL VOTED
TO REMOVE TWO CONFEDERATE
STATUES BUT A CHARLOTTESVILLE
CIRCUIT COURT JUDGE JUST WROTE
THAT THE STATUES ARE WAR
MONUMENTS THAT ARE PROTECTED
UNDER VIRGINIA STATE LAW AND
CANNOT BE MOVED WITHOUT
PERMISSION OR A CHANGE IN THE
LAW.
NEWT GINGRICH IS JOINING ME NOW,
THE FORMER SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
AND THE AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK
"COLLUSION."
THE JUDGE IS SAYING THAT PEOPLE
ARE MAKING THESE CONFEDERATE
STATUES GOT TO BE SOMETHING
OTHER THAN WHAT THEY ACTUALLY
ARE, A REMINDER OF OUR WAR
HISTORY.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> I THINK YOU MOVE TOWARDS A
TOTALITARIAN STATE WHEN YOU
START CREATING A MEMORY HOLE AND
YOU DECIDE WHICH PARTS OF THE
PAST YOU WANT TO ERASE.
YOU HAVE TO LIE ABOUT WHO YOU
ARE, IT IS FUNNY, THE LEFT HAS
DECIDED THAT ROBERT E. LEE IS
UNACCEPTABLE AND YET IN 1975 THE
SENATOR JOE BIDEN VOTED TO GIVE
HIM HIS CITIZENSHIP BACK
SOMETHING HE LOST IN THE
CIVIL WAR.
THIS REMARKABLE CHANGE, I THINK
THE WHOLE EFFORT ON THE LEFT TO
ERASE AMERICAN HISTORY IS WRONG
AND I THINK PEOPLE OUGHT TO
STAND UP FOR IT.
YOU ARE NOT STANDING UP FOR THE
VALUES OF THOSE PEOPLE WERE
STANDING UP FOR THE FACT THAT
THEY WERE A SIGNIFICANT PART OF
AMERICAN HISTORY AND DESERVE TO
BE STUDIED AS AMERICAN HISTORY
AND I THINK IN FACT STUDYING THE
ROLE OF SLAVERY AND THE
CIVIL WAR HELPS YOU BETTER
UNDERSTAND AMERICA.
>> Laura: IT UNDERSTANDS OUR
SCARS, OUR LESSONS, THE GREAT
STRUGGLE FOR FREEDOM OF ALL
PEOPLE AND IT IS BIZARRE.
HAVE YOU BEEN TO NEW ORLEANS?
THAT HUGE PEDESTAL THERE WERE
THEY REMOVED THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY KNOWS
WHERE THAT WENT.
NOW IT IS JUST A STARK REMINDER
OF THIS TALIBAN APPROACH TO
AMERICAN HISTORY.
I'M NOT ENDORSING SLAVERY, NO
ONE IS BUT THEY ARE SAYING THIS
IS WHAT WE CAME FROM AND I THINK
WE SHOULD BUILD NEW MEMORIALS TO
EXPAND THE CONVERSATION.
IT IS VERY ODD.
I WANT TO MOVE ONTO THE THE
DIRTY POLITICS IN WASHINGTON.
PRESIDENT TRUMPS REFUSAL NOW TO
COOPERATE WITH FEES AND LESS
DEMOCRAT SUBPOENAS, IT IS NOW
INTENSIFYING THE DEMOCRATS PUSH
FOR IMPEACHMENT.
>> I THINK HE HAS ESCALATED THE
CONFLICT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS PASSED THE
GAUNTLET AND HE IS PREPARED TO
FIGHT TOOTH AND NAIL AND WE ARE
PREPARED TO FIGHT HIM BACK.
>> Laura: FINALLY THEY GOT
AROUND TO EVOKING EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
OWEN MCGANN WAS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL'S OFFICE.
WHAT IS YOUR ADVICE FOR THE
PRESIDENT?
>> ESTER WITH THE OBVIOUS
REALITY, A REPUBLICAN SENATE IS
NOT GOING TO CONVEY TO THE
PRESIDENT OF ANYTHING.
IT IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
THEREFORE THE DEMOCRATS IN THE
HOUSE CAN JUMP UP AND DOWN AND
SCREAM AND HOLD THEIR BREATH
UNTIL THEY TURN PURPLE IT
DOESN'T MATTER.
THEY WILL NOT HAVE ANY ABILITY
TO GET THINGS DONE IN TERMS OF
IMPEACHMENT.
THESE PEOPLE HAVE PROVEN THEY
HAVE NO INTEREST IN THE TRUTH,
NO INTEREST IN THE FACTS AND IF
YOU GIVE AND THEY WILL JUST
DEMAND MORE.
I THINK HE IS VERY WISE TO DRAW
A FIRM LINE IN THE GROUND AND
SAY NO, WE WILL NOT.
I THINK THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
BILL BARR IS VERY WISE TO NOT
AGREE TO ALLOW LAWYERS WERE ON
THE STAFF TO ASK QUESTIONS.
IT CHANGES TOTALLY THE
RELATIONSHIP AND FRANKLY ALLOWS
PURELY PROFESSIONAL POLITICIANS
WHO ARE TRAINED LAWYERS TO SIT
IN THERE AND SPENT WEEKS
PREPARING WAYS TO TRACK.
THAT WILL DO FINE AGAINST
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS BUT NOBODY
WILL GO IN WITH THE SERIES OF
WELL-TRAINED STAFF LAWYERS THAT
DO VERY WELL.
>> Laura: IT IS PREPOSTEROUS.
AS YOU MENTIONED, HE SHOWS UP
TOMORROW AND TWO DAYS OF
TESTIMONY AND 24 HOURS AFTER
THIS REPORTED MUELLER LETTER.
BILL BARR SAYS HE IS NOT GOING
TO SHOW UP FOR THE SECOND
SESSION IF DEMOCRATS DON'T BACK
DOWN ON THEIR DEMAND FOR LIKE AN
EXTRA HOUR OF QUESTIONING BY
LAWMAKERS AND COMMITTEE
ATTORNEYS.
JERRY NADLER IS SAYING, BARR IS
IN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WILL NOT
HAVE A CHOICE.
>> IT IS NOT UP TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO TELL THE
COMMITTEE HOW TO CONDUCT THEIR
BUSINESS.
WE WILL DECIDE WHAT THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY OF ASKING
QUESTIONS ARE NOT AS OUR
DECISION.
WE WILL HAVE TO GO TO SUBPOENAS
IF HE DOESN'T SHOW UP.
>> Laura: I GUESS BRING IT, WE
WILL SEE YOU IN COURT.
ECO-THE SUBPOENA NORMALLY IS
UNENFORCEABLE.
THEY WILL NOT BE VERY EFFECTIVE
IN SUBPOENAING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THEY LOOK,
THE MORE THEY DO THIS THE MORE
TIRED THE COUNTRY WILL GET.
IF HE CAN GET THE DEMOCRATS INTO
PUBLICLY BEING SO FOCUSED ON
THIS KIND OF GAME, THE COUNTRY
WILL BE VERY TIRED OF THE
DEMOCRATS AS PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRYING TO HELP SOLVE AMERICANS
PROBLEMS.
>> Laura: I HAVE TO ASK YOU
ABOUT THE TIMING OF THIS LEAK
TONIGHT ON THE LETTER TO BARR
WHICH IS BEING COMPLETELY
MISCHARACTERIZED.
PEOPLE ARE FROTHING AT THE
MOUTH.
THEY ARE LIKE, HE WAS TELLING
HIM HE IS MISCHARACTERIZING THE
REPORT.
IT IS SO PATENTLY RIDICULOUS.
LIKE BILL BARR WOULD
MISREPRESENT THE REPORT, IT IS
CRAZY.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE TIMING?
>> I ASSUME SOMEBODY WANTED TO
LEAK IT TO MAXIMIZE THE
EMBARRASSMENT OF BARR TO SET UP
THE QUESTIONS FOR THE HEARINGS
THE NEXT TWO DAYS.
THE DEEP STATE AND WASHINGTON
HAS PLAYED THESE GAMES FOR THE
WHOLE HISTORY OF THE COUNTRY,
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING NEW.
JEFFERSON AND HAMILTON IS TO
SUBSIDIZE NEWSPAPERS TO ATTACK
EACH OTHER WHILE THEY ARE BOTH
SERVING IN THE CABINET.
WE HAVE HAD A LONG HISTORY OF
THIS STUFF.
AFTER ALL THE NOISE YOU SHRUG
YOUR SHOULDERS AND SAY SO WHAT?
HE HAD EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO COME
OUT THE DAY THAT BARR RELEASED
HIS LETTER.
MUELLER COULD HAVE AT ANY POINT
DECIDED TO REFUTE IT AND AS I
UNDERSTAND THE ACTUAL KEY
SENTENCES, THE DISTORTION IS BY
THE NEWS MEDIA.
IT IS NOT BY BARR.
>> Laura: HE SAID I DON'T
DISAGREE WITH THE OUTCOME OF
YOUR SYNOPSIS, IT WAS THE WAY
THE MEDIA WAS POUNDING.
>> THINK ABOUT THIS.
THE MEDIA THAT MUELLER IS
COMPLAINING ABOUT ARE THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE USING HIS COMPLAINT TO
FURTHER DISTORT WHAT IS GOING
ON.
YOU COULDN'T MAKE THIS UP.
>> Laura: WANT TO CONGRATULATE
YOU, YOUR NEW BOOK IS OUT TODAY
CALLED "COLLUSION."
IT IS A NOVEL AND EVERYBODY HAS
TO READ IT.
IT IS NOT ABOUT MUELLER!
IT IS SO TYPICAL TO JUST TIME IT